(upbeat music)
- In vitro fertilization is a process
where a woman's eggs are
fertilized outside her body
then placed back inside her
body to help her get pregnant.
A woman's reproductive
system includes the vagina,
cervix,
uterus,
fallopian tubes,
and ovaries.
During the monthly menstrual cycle,
one of the ovaries releases an egg
in a process called ovulation.
After ovulation, the egg
enters the fallopian tube.
A woman is most likely to
become pregnant if she has sex
in the days just before, during,
or right after ovulation.
During this time a sperm cell
from a man's reproductive
fluid, called semen,
is able to fertilize the egg
just inside the fallopian tube.
As it travels along the fallopian tube
the fertilized egg now called an embryo
loses the outer cells that
nourished it in the ovary.
The embryo passes from the
fallopian tube into the uterus.
In the uterus the embryo sheds
its protective outer layer,
called the zona pellucida,
in a process called zona hatching.
Zona hatching is necessary
for the embryo to implant
in the tissue lining the uterus.
During implantation a
connection between the woman
and the embryo begins to grow.
This organ, called the placenta,
allows oxygen and nutrients to
pass from her to the embryo.
In vitro fertilization may be performed
if a woman has been having
trouble getting pregnant,
a condition known as infertility,
or it may be done if a
woman wants to have a child
without a male partner.
Before in vitro fertilization
a woman will receive
fertility medication that
causes more than one egg to grow
and mature in the ovaries.
A man will provide a semen sample
so that the healthiest
sperm can be collected
for fertilization.
If the male partner is
completely infertile,
also known as sterile,
or the woman doesn't have a male partner,
a donor may be arranged to
provide sperm for this process.
In vitro fertilization consists
of three main procedures,
follicle aspiration,
fertilization,
and embryo transfer.
During the first procedure,
called follicle aspiration,
eggs will be harvested from the ovaries.
At the beginning of this procedure
an ultrasound probe will be
inserted into the woman's vagina
so that her doctor can view her ovaries.
Inside the ovaries the doctor
will look for follicles.
Each follicle is a fluid filled
sack that contains an egg.
Then the doctor will
insert a long thin needle
into and through the wall of her vagina,
and guide it to the ovary.
A suction device connected to the needle
will collect several eggs
from inside their follicles.
During the second part of
in vitro fertilization,
called fertilization,
the collected eggs will
be taken immediately
to a laboratory where
they will be fertilized.
Fertilization may be
performed by insemination
where several sperm are mixed
with the healthiest eggs,
or the eggs may be fertilized
with sperm injected
directly into them during a process called
intracytoplasmic sperm injection.
The fertilized eggs, also called embryos,
will be monitored for three to five days
as they begin to grow.
At this time the lab may create
a hole in the zona pellucida
surrounding some of the embryos.
This process, called assisted hatching,
will help these embryos
implant in the uterus.
Some of the embryos
will be used right away
for embryo transfer,
and the rest will be frozen
and stored for future use
if necessary.
The third part of in vitro fertilization
is called embryo transfer,
which is done three to five
days after fertilization.
During embryo transfer,
a tool called a speculum will be inserted
into the woman's vagina
so that the doctor can see
her cervix.
A syringe will be loaded
with fluid containing one
or more of the hatched embryos.
Then the syringe will be
attached to a long thin tube
called a catheter.
The doctor will insert the
catheter into the vagina
through the cervix and into the uterus.
Once inside the uterus, the
doctor will inject the embryos.
Then the catheter and
speculum will be removed.
The woman may continue to lie on her back
for about 15 minutes.